I love your album live at Carnegie Hall
thank you I think it's lassic and
everybody's to check out there and my
some of my favorite bits are about your
kids as children I want to spackle that
wall my impression of you isn't even use
that a you're tweaking I don't really
sound like that I don't you're goofing
it up a bit I'm certainly I'm certainly
goofing it out but it's flattering right
absolutely
well me and Orrin right there made
Romano sings the Paris video was it
seven years ago or something and we
heard it made its way to your wife and
then we heard that the question you had
was are they making fun and we I wrote
this huge email I don't know if it got
back to you I was like please forward
this to him we're huge fans it's an
homage it's a it's out of respect I
sound Italian now it's all out of
respect no no make a phone call could
you close your eyes Hey cancel the phone
call I was kidding
Wow it's not good if that's what I sound
like I owe my wife an apology I really
[Music]